I'm concerned you might not be of age. I would like to see proof.
No, I will not prove I am of age. However, I am at least real.
Good enough. You may be a minor, but at least you're a real minor.
>> That's pretty good. >> Connor counterpoints would
literally hold a child down while Destiny them and just chastise
him the whole time. Destiny, this is so bad. It's like holding
the kid down. Destiny, this is so bad. You should stop doing
this. This is like totally crazy right now.
>> Wild stuff. Hello. Who's this? >> It's me. It's
Lav. >> What's up, Lav? How's it going? >> What's
the latest and greatest?
>> What's the latest and greatest? Um,
Destiny basically tried to file a thing saying he didn't exchange
material with a minor in his court case, right? The Rose person.
that apparently uh there was a third party, the solo person was
the intermediary between Rose and Destiny. So Destiny and Rose
knew each other >> and sorry no that wrong. Solo and Rose
knew each other. They were like boyfriend girlfriend or something
and but he was an adult apparently sex trafficking her. And Destiny's
argument is actually I'm totally in the clear because I was only
sending the material to an adult who was masquerading as the
minor that he thought was 18 apparently. So he's like basically
this is like totally Oh, I don't know if you're in the presentation,
but this is totally fine with the middleman. >> Yeah, it's
totally good. We're all good here. This is fine,
right? And it's not exchanging material because there's this
middleman here even though Dendi Destiny sends
material to Solo who forwards it to Rose and then Rose based
on request sends sexual material back to Destiny. >> Oh
no, I just put Connor the Connor seal of approval on a bunch
of things.
>> Conor's a big fan. Conor's a big fan. >> Yeah.
Jeez Louise.
>> Yeah. So he's like trying to run through and explain
to his audience. Totally
>> Yeah. He's right on technicality. He's right on a technicality.
No.
>> Oh, but they argued that because he didn't know she
was a minor anyway, it was fine. So, like this doesn't actually
change anything, right? Or what do you Sorry. What do you think
it changes?
>> I don't think it changes anything. There's just no like
crime I think being committed that he can like be
well in especially he's not going to get in trouble cuz this
is like just
for another court case, right? >> Um Yeah. So, the reason
this got litigated And even for the court case, like a judge
isn't going to be like, "Oh, this is yeah, this is indicative
of good moral character."
>> Well, I think probably I would expect a lot of this
stuff, especially depending on how it gets litigated down. I'd
expect some of this stuff to get stricken before it goes to court.
Like, you're not going to just be able to call Destiny a in in
rulings or in motions and then have that stick and and like stay
there. I just think he's mad because it's getting filed publicly,
right? So he said that this person was like 19,
right? And so they corrected and said actually she was 17 at
the time. Person whose material he got was 17 at the time. And
then they tried to he tried to sanction Pixie's team. Jesus.
He tried to sanction Pixie's team and said that she was lying
and like there was due to the dep after the deposition it was
like clear that this person was she was act he was actually talking
to like an adult and then and that her saying exchanging was
was happening was totally wrong. And he his argument was it's
not exchanging because I didn't send my material to her. I only
received it from her.
It was very interesting to me. I don't know. I very neat.
And then Pixie basically came out and said, "No, no, no. Actually,
she testified that she was forwarded videos of you as well."
So their argument is, "No, it's an exchange because it's going
through an intermediary, but there's like actual exchange happening."
Very glitchpole coded debate
>> Yeah. Is that still like illegal? Do you still get in
trouble for that? Do you still like Would Jon still get in trouble
for
>> for soliciting from somebody? Yeah, probably.
The issue The issue with Destiny, he might be able to get off
on um on getting these videos, but I do believe Solo tells him
about the videos
on getting those videos. >> Yeah, he definitely got off
on them. Yeah, but he might have to get off. He might get off
criminally. Okay.
Uh as well. And
and so with uh with this guy being here, it doesn't really I
don't know. It's um Oh, sorry. I know what I was saying now.
Sorry. He might get off uh on charges off of all charges with
regards to this if he immediately once he was informed that she
was a minor gone to the cops and said like, "Hey, I was sent
this. I didn't know what it was. I got to I got to do the right
thing." Right? Or even if he just deleted it immediately, but
he like verifiably and admitted to retaining it and then said
his lawyers told him to retain it. So >> I'm pretty sure
you can't do that in the state of Florida. Pretty sure that's
a
>> So yeah. Yeah. We'll see. We'll see if they look into
it.
>> Oh yeah. He also it seems like he's admitting to he
was trying to find this person in a group chat and it seemed
like he was sending material to this group chat and there are
some leaks that we can't verify but purported leaks like it's
basically somebody leaked to someone on Kiwi Farms. Okay. So,
not not high degree of certainty, but Destiny's also like
this is also where we learned about this Discord group and he
like acknowledged the Discord group existed. The original email
that it was sent with though said that he sent the to the Discord
group. Oh, reactive won't be fixed, guys. I unfortunately didn't
go fix it between stream. >> So, he was trying to find
Rose and he had sent like even the of her to the Discord group.
>> Why did he do that?
>> Uh, he's psychotic.
He's like totally crazy in every way, you know. >> Jeez,
this guy's a mess. >> He is a mess.
Hold on. Let me try I'm going to try something real quick. Let's
see if this works. God damn. Hold on. I'm going to try to get
your face on screen. Give me a second. He's a big goofy guy.
Oh, never mind. I can't. Dude, why did they They just totally
ruined reactive Discord. It's like kind of
>> In the leaks, it was said that other members of the
group had to tell them to stop sending the C
>> that's awesome. Alive. Are you an ass or arms girl?
Neither. I'm a big tummy girl. I like a big hairy gut. >> Okay,
never mind. This isn't going to work. It reactive Discord won't
work. Too bad. Gross. You just said gross. So anyway, we're uh
we're watching this. We're just watching him go through and um
and cope.
Very good times. Very good >> All my
whoever was running the account was leaking all my I want to
know who the it was. I think I had that right. And since your
client is too actually file a court case cuz the person who leaked
everything apparently I'm the only one that can find any of this.
So yeah, I was trying to find out who the [__] person
was. Oh, he also is like
he's super inconsistent through like his own arguments throughout
the stream. It's very funny. So like he's basically soying the
out cuz they're like oh you know Rose testified that Destiny
had sent the or Rose testified that Destiny sent stuff to a Discord
group and he's like yeah I did do that cuz I was trying to find
these people but also he admitted that he's got like Solo's information
within his like payment processor but he won't subpoena it cuz
he he won't file a court case cuz he's too emotionally distraught
to handle like chasing down Solo and filing that court case which
would just be criminal and fighting Pixie in court at the same
time. So he's like letting the child trafficker he's complaining
about go. So he'll simultaneously say the child trafficker is
the most evil person and these guys are defending him by calling
me a monster, but also he's the only person who has any information
on the child trafficker and he's too emotionally distraught to
provide any of that to the police or to anyone. So he's doxed
Rose. He's doxed a bunch of people around this case, but he won't
dox this one international child sex trafficker. Very interesting.
>> Maybe he's running out of money. >> I assume the
money is not fun. Like losing the money from the case is not
fun. But
I don't know. It's hard to say. You know, he got demonetized
on YouTube, too, right? >> Oh, no. I didn't know that.
>> Yeah. A couple months ago.
>> Is he's still streaming on kick though?
>> Yeah. He probably makes a decent amount of money streaming
on kick. But like >> that's not his biggest platform is
I frequently feel like I see him and it's like a thousand viewers.
>> Yeah. Um, he streams on like a
he streams on YouTube now,
like still. And he had like good viewers today. I think he had
like 8 9,000 viewers today, but he's covering his court case
stuff. So, a lot of people are like very excited about that.
>> Yeah. It's so crazy that he's doing that. I can't I
can't even imagine the conversations he's having with his lawyer
where his lawyer's like, "Dude, there's no way you're still doing
this."
>> It's a little goofy.
It's a little goofy, man. Um,
it it's better now than it was. He was like going on he he complained
in here about how Pixie tried to subpoena his logs with like
food shops and it's like but he went on food shops' stream and
was like actually leaking things to food
Like there's every reason they should probably want to subpoena
those logs. He'd be like, "Oh, look at the she'd be like reading
a legal file. He'd be like, "Look, they're lying. Look at this
thing I sent." It's like, "Okay, I feel like probably they think
that's interesting or relevant to the case." No. Seems >> God,
this guy is so sad. >> It is. I I'll be honest. He So,
I don't know if you know this as well. He recently threatened
to dox Wicked Supreme and esports Batman. I don't know if you
know esports Batman at all, but you know, >> I don't know
if you Yeah. >> Yeah. Yeah. And it's like literally the
Supreme doesn't say anything crazy. He just like sometimes he
argues with people who come into the the server and like want
to defend Destiny on something and sometimes he'll just argue
with them a little bit and be like you're look
and then Destiny has started threatening to dox like everybody
in my discord. It's kind of crazy. So I was sorry all that is
saying yes he is very sad >> doxing people now like he's
just like that's his thing now. >> Oh he's doxed multiple
people in the past like couple weeks. Yeah. Yep.
>> Yeah. He's just like the he's the doxer. He's the doxing
community. Esports Batman was a lawyer who would come in his
streams for years. Is that not Is Pisco Pisco and esports best
Batman are they different people? >> They were like they
were like sort of um rivals kind of.
>> in that
uh Yeah. kind of rivals. Yep. Yep. Yeah. He's like openly he
goes to like his chat [laughter] post docks of
Dude, if he talks to me, my husband would literally hold him
down and and kill him in a video game. >> He can do whatever
he wants to. I'm coming to his house.
>> Okay, we totally disavow. That's not
>> I'm coming to >> Okay. All right. Goofy.
Um, yeah. What's up? What's new? What's going on? >> Nothing.
Nothing's really new. Nothing's really Oh, I guess I I I was
going to meet the Thorps. >> I was going to cover that
content at some point. I might cover that at some point later.
>> Yeah, I was going to meet the Thorps, but then I was
like, "Hey, I like while we're together, I don't want you to
make like advances at me. I don't want to be be touched by Ben,
and I like I'm not going to stick around if you're like talking
about my husband." And Ben flipped out and was like, "You can't
tell people what to do when they meet up with you." And and I
was like, "Okay, well then I'm not come like I'm not going to
hang out with you then. Like I actually can just like choose
not to hang out with you then." And um and so I was like, "Don't
come. Don't drive the rest of the way to from wherever from Rhode
Island to here if you're like going to be upset that I'm not
meeting up with you." And then
>> Grace was like, "Okay, well you and me and Lo can go
hang out." And I was like, "Okay, that's fine as long as Ben's
not there." And then they like tried to trap me to like hang
out with them. And I was just like, "Yeah, no. I'm not going
to go hang out with Ben." And then Ben freak wrote and then Grace
got so day drunk, like extremely daydrunk on stream and started
crying about how she was scared I'm I'm going to like be mean
to her or something because she like is fat. I don't know. And
uh and then >> to be fair, that's an incredibly appropriate
fear to have.
>> I don't think I don't think so at all. I'm I'm exceedingly
nice in person. Um,
and I didn't have like really >> Well, there was a there's
a little part in there that I have not experienced. So, I'm extremely
nice in person. >> Well, I am nice in person. And I'm especially
nice if you don't if you haven't like tried to like with me in
any way. The Thorps have never tried to with me. Like, what reason
do I have to be like mean to Grace?
>> Yeah, that's fair. That's fair. >> Like I don't
I didn't have any reason to be mean to Grace. We were like totally
cordial.
Um >> Yeah, that's fine. But
but yeah, it and then it just ended up being like a huge a huge
thing. I don't know if I told you this, but after uh after TwitchCon,
I like heard through the grapevine that that Kyla was talking
about me, but the she was talking was like she's really she's
like way too nice in person. Like that's what she like that's
the she was talking about.
>> Oh, she wanted you to be like a total [__]
in person so so she could be like, "Oh, this person sucks."
Yeah, I guess so. But I heard from multiple people they're like,
"Yeah, we were at a party and she was like talking about you
talking about how nice you were in person." I'm like, "Okay."
Like that's that's what you're going to that's the that you're
talking about me. Yeah. It was weird. But >> very weird.
Very weird. >> But uh but yeah, I cuz I I came up to her
and I was not I'm friends with her husband and we were and I
was and her husband was like telling me where they were and so
I was like, "Okay, I'll go I'll go say hi, meet up with them."
Cuz they were also with Jeb. I'm I'm you know I've been friendly
with Jeb throughout the years and they had like a little gang
going with like enemy Charlie who I'm you know uh tangentially
friends with because my husband
and uh so I went over to like say hi and I even was like hi oh
my god kind of like you're so >> Hold on hold on hold on
>> can I ask you one question? Are you like a little mad
that she got Andrew Wilson's scalp and you didn't? >> Little
mad little annoyed.
>> The Charlie person. That's enemy Charlie, right? Is
the person who got Andrew Wilson on >> I don't I don't
even have beef with with Andrew Wilson. I think it's funny.
I'm glad that someone did. It didn't have to be me. >> I'll
be honest. I didn't think she didn't like get him bad at all.
It was all his reaction, right? Like his reaction was just like
so over the top that it became something. I feel like she wasn't
He could have said all the things he said just in a more calm
fashion and would have been fine. I don't know. >> He totally
fumbled. He totally totally fumbled cuz it he actually like it
does not make him less of a Christian to like become apparent
to another woman's it actually that's like not against Christianity
that like it makes him actually a better Christian that he would
do something like that. But it he reacted like he was emasculated
by it which was the problem. And he looked so gay. He looked
so gay doing that. He kept saying snizz over and over again.
It's like, bro, just say she's like a boxy. Like, literally just
call her a >> You lookense.
>> Yeah. Like, like, I'm sorry. I hate to say it, but you
got to you got to get Brian's channel banned. Okay, that's the
only option here. Don't also disavow the slurs. My bad. But um
like just call like literally just be you. But he like tried
to censor himself. He sounded so gay. You like Sn? You like Sn
actually? What the? Yeah, he I think he kind of frequently sounds
gay, but
but yeah, no, I'm glad that I'm glad that she
>> I'm glad that that had, you know, a viral moment
and seeing them cope on the timeline about it was crazy also,
but it is what it is. But yeah, I went up to Kyla. I went up
to Kyla and I was like, uh, you are so gorgeous in person. Like,
you are so strikingly beautiful in person. And she was like,
okay.
I was like, okay, we're moving on. But she was like I was like
maybe she's anxious or something. She just doesn't like me. But
I'm like you know whatever. I like I went out of my way. I mean
she is she's she's much more beautiful in person than you'd expect.
Like much much much more be like striking.
>> Oh her connection she connection that
>> Oh no. What happened?
>> You were raving about how beautiful Aridite was in person
and then your connection died. >> Oh no. But yeah, she
is she is very strikingly beautiful in person and I told her
that and she did not seem like she wanted to hear it from me.
But that's okay. >> Well,
I thought Wait, did she not talk to you at all?
>> Uh, barely. Bar like not any more than she had to. And
I think it was just like hi and like nods and like maybe a quiet
thank you. But everyone else was >> so it was her silence
was definitely strange and noted. Well, you did point out that
she thought you were being sarcastic while we were streaming.
I definitely was not. I don't think there's any chance she thought
I was being sarcastic.
>> Do you remember that moment from the stream where we're
watching her like debate and you pointed out the zit and then
we paused and zoomed on? >> You just said it was distracting.
It was Everyone gets zits. >> Dude, [laughter] why are
you doing this? Don't click that link that was in chat. Okay,
don't do
>> Oh my god, I'm scared. I already did.
>> Wait, that's the scariest picture I've ever seen. Wait,
I'm like I actually can't look at it. It's like giving me the
heeie-jeebies
>> and jibbing.
>> To be fair, I had my I had my big natty out, my big
naturals out, and she probably was like, "Fuck."
I probably just got her wet under the table. She like didn't
know what to say.
>> I can hear the extra 5 lbs live put on over Thanksgiving.
No, I actually lost so much weight over the past couple
I'm actually >> That's not good. >> Yeah, I'm trying
to get my weight back
>> No, actually. Yeah, cuz I started to >> If you
lose too much weight as a curvy girl, you don't actually look
better. You just look deflated, which is not the move. That's
real. >> I think >> that's real. >> Sure. I
was just thinking like during the scavenger hunt, I was like,
"Oh, this person's very skinny." There's some other stuff. You're
like very skinny. Okay. I'm like, then you're like, "Oh, I lost
even more weight." Like, no, don't do that. Don't. >> Yeah,
I lost from the scavenger hunt, I've probably lost like like
12 lbs, which is pretty significant cuz I'm 5'1. >> That
sounds like if you put your measurements into like a BMI calculator,
it's going to go like, you're about to die, actually. >> No,
no, no. I'm just under normal for BMI. Just under normal, but
I'll be back to normal soon. >> Yeah, I look like Merc
now. No, it would I would have to be like 80 lbs to look like
Merc. Merc is like very underweight right now. Merc needs to
get fat again. We need to start that initiative.
Okay. I don't think she was fat before. What the [__]
>> She was She was chubby. >> Saying right now
the perk was chubby. She literally was >> I feel like you're
going crazy right now. I feel like you're going crazy right now.
>> What do you mean?
There's nothing wrong with being chubby. It looks good on her.
She looks better with a little bit of weight.
>> She was I I'm a for I think Merc is one of the most
beautiful streamers. I think she's a very beautiful face. You
can't tell right now because she looks like Voldemort, but before
the Ozump she was gorgeous.
[laughter]
>> Jesus Christ. Why the cattiness? >> You guys have
never been around gay men and it shows. You guys have never been
around gay men and it shows. >> The only gay guys I know
were like from university and compsai and yeah, they there were
no women around so they couldn't even be catty against women.
>> Women just didn't. >> Yeah, this is like this
is called This is called a read. This is called a read.
Read you wrote you. This is a little read. This is like a little,
you know, I'm reading.
>> I don't know. >> Okay. Well, that's it's out of
love. It's It's very light-hearted. It's very
>> Okay. Well, if it's lighthearted,
>> it is. But anyway, yeah, I so the the Thorps went insane
and then I and then they kept going insane
and then they never stopped and then I got home and I and then
Lo got me sick.
>> It's almost like they were insane before. It's almost
like they were in like the 99th iteration of being insane and
you just kind of at that moment >> you never know who's
doing their character as like a bit or who's doing their character
as like real. There's a lot of people I've met online who are
very normal in person, like my husband and me who like have a
character online and then you meet them in person or like Mr.
Girl and it's very like normal and sweet and nice. >> Wait,
Max, there's no way Max is a different person in person. What
do you >> I didn't say different person. I just said character.
You definitely play up different facets of your personality.
He's not He's not putting on a whole different thing.
>> But I thought that that's what they were doing. Like
I thought that they were wacky. There was no chance that I didn't
think the Thorps were wacky, but I didn't think that they were
like
>> I thought they were like
contentrained.
Like Darius also Darius is not normal in person, but he's definitely
like bigger online. You know what I mean? Like everyone is a
little is different in person or they used to be.
>> Now it's hard to tell. >> I mean, I I mean, you
went to the scavenger hunt. Aren't all those people basically
the same person all the time?
uh some of them are the new streamers, the new ones that are
being like
the new ones are too contentrained and they like they've lost
themselves completely. But like the old ones from like two or
three years ago are all pretty normal. >> Okay. All right.
Interesting. They could turn it on and off, but people don't
do that anymore. >> Yeah, that's fair. Do you want to uh
do you want to keep watching this content with me? You feel like
you're sufficiently caught up? >> Yeah, sure. Okay, let's
let's give it a go. Let's see. I think Where were we at here?
Oh, we were just going through all of the the crazy Oh, we could
we give this another quick listen. This was like the big part
of the This is the big part of the whole filing here is him going
through this stuff. >> Damn, that's Wait, can I get a wizard
or like druid avatar?
>> Um, you could, but I would have to restart my OBS to
get the overlays to work right now. It's super annoying, actually.
Oh, wait, wait, wait. Hold on.
>> Uh, no, no, no. Hold on. I can just do >> Give
me a second. >> Like a bo. >> No, no. I'll just do
I'll just do something to like make this work for now. I'll just
like hack it in. Give me a second. >> Make me black, Jarvis.
Make her black. >> A second,
>> Jarvis. Make her
18 ft tall. Jarvis, give her a tail. Jarvis,
let's up the Chinese by
38%.
>> Okay, I'll just I'll just add this in. It's just from
like the Discord window. And then this works to just show when
lab is talking. I think
>> Jarvis,
make her 1200 years old in a 12year-old Chinese body.
>> you good?
>> Okay. Okay. Good. >> Rather that Rose's age material
will be because when you're a lawyer, you make multiple arguments.
>> Oh, hold on. We're still not back far enough. Here we
go. >> Bon's rule of emotion is devoid of any legal discussion
about the relevance of similar acts by Bell coupled with the
unsupportable nature of his factual contentions. Bunnell's arguments
amount to no more than conclusory and misleading contentions.
Quoting the legal standard. What else? Oh, guys, uh, four subs
away from two more hours of the stream. We have another hour
no matter what, but four subs from two more hours of characterization
of the facts misleading. As an initial matter, it should be noted
that the bundle does not actually dispute that um, this person,
screen named Rose, here after Rose, was a minor when pornographic
materials were exchanged prior to her October 2022 birthday.
Just as plain to have accurately noted in the footnote.
That's that's not exactly what you said in the footnote, but
okay. >> Oh, update really quick update. his his ex ex-girlfriend
ex-girlfriend or
le what's her name Lena something like that
>> followed me on Twitter recently
>> don't know what that's about don't know what that's
about
something a little interesting >> yeah okayhuh
>> just something just a little >> a little interesting
I wonder what's I wonder what uh what that's happening wonder
What happened? >> Yeah, I do wonder. I do wonder. >> Um,
do entry 183 at 106 defendant arguing rather that Rose is a immaterial.
Well, because when you're a lawyer, you make multiple arguments
at the same time.
>> Did you catch that? So, Destiny is saying he's reading
this and they say, "Well, um, Destiny never disputed that Rose
was under 18." And he goes, "Yeah, but when you're a lawyer,
you make multiple arguments at the same time." It's like, "Yeah,
but did you dispute it then? You're literally giving me a reason
you should dispute it. that you make multiple arguments, but
he hasn't.
>> This person named Rose here after Rose was a minor when
pornographic materials were exchanged prior to her October 2022
birthday. Justice plately noted in the >> Oh my god, she's
a Scorpio.
>> Back to what you said in the footnote, but okay.
>> Um, do entry 183 at 106 defendant arguing rather that
Rose is a immaterial. Well, because when you're a lawyer, you
make multiple arguments at the same time, right? That's why you
have five different arguments here and not just one because you
always make every argument you can, right? And
>> so it's immaterial, but she's also not a minor, right?
Not just it's immaterial. >> Apparently concerned enough
about Rose having been a minor at the time that he raised the
issue at her deposition. A fact Bunnel fails to disclose in his
wrote of emotion. What does this have to do with anything? Exhibit
A, the declaration blah blah blah.
Bonel himself generally refers to exchanges material between
Bunnel and Rose in the same manner plaintiff did in the footnote
and tellingly raised no such objection to the footnote therein.
Yeah, because we didn't have the information at the time. Why
am I even reading this? I'm just kidding. It's just here. This
just to troll me. [sighs]
I do think it's bad. They they say at the time he could obviously
file something to amend his complaint. His uh not complaint,
but his um
motion.
Yes.
>> Is he still in Florida? >> Yeah, I think so. I
think that's still the same apartment. I'm not sure though. Hard
to say >> if just the con theion
is a crime. Um it is uh the like holding >> any person
in the state who knew or reasonably should have known that he
or she was transmitting.
>> H doesn't look like it doesn't look like
beyond a reasonable doubt. Eh I don't
>> Wait, so
you know that the solo person told him that she was a minor,
right?
>> Oh no, I did not know that. What? in November of 2024.
>> Wait, but he said that girl is a minor.
>> Wait, but after he had sent her things.
>> Yes, but then he retained the videos he got from her
and sent like pictures from the videos into a group chat to try
to identify her. Yes. >> Cuz he didn't believe that he
thought that guy was lying. To be fair, and I'll say this for
the like eighth time, I also thought that guy was lying, but
it's like I'm like 90% sure that guy's lying. And in the 10%
chance he is, don't risk going to prison. Don't keep Don't keep
child, dude. >> Yeah, of course not. Geez. >> Has
the GC stuff been proven? Oh, Ozel, he's admitted to it multiple
times. He straight up has just said, "Yes, the Discord exists.
Yes, that Discord chat existed." When when it's referred to in
here, he literally just says, "Yeah, that chat existed." Now,
in terms of him saying like the the to that chat, that's not
verified. Um he hasn't given details. So, it's possible that
that email that was posted was
>> Asked you to feed him from a bottle.
>> Jesus Christ. >> Yes. He asked He said he said,
"Please, mama, upg
no, no, no. We don't need to do that. We're good." It is apparently
clear that Binell's argument boils down to an objection to the
relevance of Rose's age at the time. But he ba and he bases this
objection on representations to this court which are however
anything but
Specifically, Binell posits that the fact that Rose is a minor
is irrelevant because one, Rose's then boyfriend solo was catfishing
by. Two, Rose was not directly operating the social media account
through which materials were exchanged, any of the accounts by
the way. And three, Rose did not see any plaintist material materials.
Um, do you >> Yeah. So, like basically I think
he probably had no way of knowing that she Well, sorry. He he
did ask her. I I fully believe cuz he he hinted at this that
he basically asked for ID or something, right? >> Like
there was every reason to believe there was a ton of red No,
there's a ton of red flags that were like basically Dude, this
is a this is really dicey.
>> Yeah. He's like, "You need to show me your ID, but it's
not that big of a deal if you don't." She's like, "Oh no, I lost
it." He's like, "Okay, send the nudes." Yeah,
that is factually what happened, by the way. Verbata. >> But
he but he uh
>> but like he he did I think confirm that she was like
19. Like he was like, "You're 19, right?" [laughter] >> Oh
my god. >> Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. There's a good There's
a good reenactment of this. There's a good reenactment of this.
Hold on. Um >> Sorry. I left my ID at my my ID at my babysitter's
house. I don't have it on me. Oh, >> where's the line?
Somebody sent me the
[__] I don't remember the scene it's from. I've never
seen the movie, dude. It's the It's the Leon the Professional
scene. Somebody send me that tweet right >> Dude, are you
paying your guys? These people who you're who you're making do
your content for you? Are you paying them or is this just free
labor? You're exploiting them. >> Here it is. Here it is.
Here it is. >> How old are you?
>> Want to see my license?
>> No.
You just look a little younger. >> Actual actually true
to life right there. Okay. This is why DG loves this movie apparently.
>> You know who else would love this movie? Max Carson
>> probably. I don't know what the movie's about to be
honest. I think this guy's a killer, isn't he? Isn't he like
a assassin or something? >> Yeah, the movie is actually
like kind of mid, but
the the acting is good, but the movie the plot is like
>> Fair enough. Sorry that but that this is like actually
what happened
very goofy
very silly stuff at one despite the fact that it is patently
improper to force plaintiff to litigate these highly disputed
factual issues at this stage of the case but the reason set forth
in sections two and three infra plaintiff addresses why b's contentious
problematic >> oh wait hold on hold on hold on apparently
I'm supposed to look at this clip too one secondly
we're supposed to take a look at this >> I like how you
always seem to drop me into the one warm spot in this whole cold
cake. >> Yeah. And I uh I like how you're at least 18 years
old. >> Actually, I'm >> I like how you're at least
18 years old. Her nickname was Baby, which means over 18 years
old. Anyway, we were falling in love. But then >> that's
awesome. That rocks.
>> Wild. Then why are you putting them in foot? Wait, wait,
wait. One, one more. One more quick meme. One more quick meme.
I'm concerned you might not be of age. I would like to see proof.
No, I will not prove I am of age. However, I am at least real.
Good enough. You may be a minor, but at least you're a real >> That's
pretty good.
>> for a plaint of addresses, why
contentious problematic? >> Then why are you putting them
in footnotes? Then why would you put >> when he says the
word footnotes?
>> Jesus.
Uh, he might he might try not to speculate on these things. These
are This is what they call in the totally deranged cult business.
Unhinged. That's an unhinged thing to say. Okay. Totally deranged
cults would refer to that comment is un give me a second. Let's
look at this footnote real quick. Okay. Age. No, no, no. 17 years
old. No, no, no. Birth. Oh, yes. Yes. Yeah. Right here. So, two.
So, hold on. See where is the two here. Despite the clear directive
from the court, defendant failed to submit any corroborating
evidence from Rose and instead simply submitted the same evidence
that the court already rejected.
Two, in fact, it is plaintiff, not defendant, that has made efforts
to obtain evidence from
Okay. Um, plaintiff hired a private investigator to ascertain
Rose's legal identity and location and has just this week managed
to serve Rose with subpoena duchum and to appear at a deposition.
and finally astainating after finally ascertaining Rose's legal
identity. Plaintiff has obtained evidence that Rose's birth date
of birth is October 30th, 2024. That's when Banell was exchanging
content with Rose between March of 2022 and until October 30th
of 2022. Rose was a minor. So exchanging content with um
sending content to and receiving content of a from a minor purportedly.
But sorry, not a minor purportedly from a young woman
>> and it was actually a child trafficker who was trafficking
a minor that he did not was not aware it was a minor.
>> Was I like not hot enough as a kid to get sex trafficked?
I feel like I I don't have any drama. Was I Why did anyone want
me?
>> Were you fat?
>> Oh well, I don't know. Do you know what that does to
a woman to be to not be desirable enough as a child
multiple times for multiple people? It's actually a It's actually
a real thing. Yes. >> Like actually up. Why did anyone
want me? Whatever. That's why I became as an adult cuz I wasn't
given enough adult attention as a child. >> Hold on, bro.
Why Why is every clip of this so long? What the I just wanted
the one I just wanted the one moment. >> Daddy out.
What's up, Will?
Without him, he never even sent ME A DAMN CAR. WITH [screaming]
him
>> lab POV. Okay, >> I ain't need him then and I
don't need him now. >> I'm Uncle Phil. >> Will you
know what, Uncle Phil? I'm going to get through college without
him. I'm going to get a great job with that CUZ AIN'T A DAMN
thing he COULD EVER TEACH ME ABOUT HOW TO LOVE MY KIDS. >> WOW.
I sympathize with the black plight. >> How come you don't
want me, man? >> Lab with every adult as she was a child.
Okay. Every every time you weren't as a kid, it's every single
time. It's so >> Me when I was me when I was 13 having
to pick up my mom at the bar with her car.
>> Those are the days.
Didn't know about that one. That's new. Footnote by Elements,
for example, that Rose also testif.
There were no bites. >> I don't think that's true. I thought
she said that happened before, like when you were like 17 on
Craigslist. No. Is that but I but nobody but everyone thought
that I was 18.
>> Nobody nobody was really willing to take nobody wanted
me so bad they were willing to go to jail. >> T's been
sent to Rose over the imposttor account. C exhibit A. Um blah
blah blah. I don't know. Rose that she was shown a handful of
videos of Destiny sent via the imposttor account.
Oh, we've got like another hour. Um I think we're four subs from
two more hours. Let's put the other hour on right now just in
case it goes over. was also testified that Solo shared with her
the Discord messages exchanged with Banell. I'm not sending these
though. I'm not the one sending these. Your stupid didn't name
Solo as a party to the case. You're not suing him. You're suing
me. I'm not the one sending these things to that other person.
>> But you said you contended with her saying exchanged.
He's saying it was exchanged. Your stuff was sent to her. Her
stuff was sent to you. That's an exchange. It went through an
intermediary. Yes. A child sex trafficker intermediary. Yes,
that's
This is all just them correcting. And then he goes, "That's not
relevant." Well, why are you getting Why did you say something
that wasn't true that they have to correct you on? Why did you
bring it up first? >> Do you think is in the child trafficking
>> I don't know. Probably lots seems like a rare good
>> Um maybe
>> like a female Epstein. You're like, I'm I'm genetically
built for this. >> It's worth a shot.
>> Yeah, maybe. Maybe maybe. and that she >> uh anonymous
and private hawk. Thank you for the gift
and videos um that she took of herself would be provided to Banell.
Rose further testified that she does not know the plaintiff.
Um this is important because if Rose does not know the plaintiff,
she could not know one way or another whether one of the handful
of videos that Destiny sent depicted
because you cuz stuff has come out afterwards because stuff was
leaked online. I'm getting one guide. I thought people didn't
really remember stuff from two years ago. Steve, I thought that's
why all of your lies made sense cuz they don't you don't really
remember stuff from 2 years ago. How is she supposed to remember
this buddy? >> I'm not getting one guide. Based on these
facts, the question whether Rose ever saw plan materials is anything
but undisputed. Even if she So Pixie So Pixie sent Holy Pixie
sent to a child. Is that what we're saying now? Is this the Is
this the transitive property of bad legal arguments? Damn.
So she if if she was saying that you sent material to
uh what would you call it like um to
directly or something if she was like very specific about it
that might count but she's basically she's saying that this occurred
when she says exchange through an intermediary and I think she
should have meant her thing to say through an intermediary.
I think that would make sense. What's
>> Cuz like Destiny thought this Sorry. Other than the
minor part. Okay. If I could get rid of the minor part, Destiny
thought it was a direct exchange, right? But it was actually
an exchange with a
So on intent on what he thought he thought he was exchanging
directly
and then in actuality he was exchanging through a middleman.
But either way is still an exchange going on.
Yeah.
I I don't know if you noticed this. You probably have noticed
this. His only response to anything is just performative exasperation.
He like never actually talks about why somebody's wrong anymore.
Like ever. He never does. It's why all of the people who go he
used to have a like a fairly good strategy. He would go and he
would like >> crying in this >> good points.
>> He almost always looks like he's crying. >> All right.
It's very srending time for
>> He used to give people good arguments. He used to actually
do that. There was something too. There was like a method to
the madness. The the arguments were good and so people who argued
from his points could convince other people. But on this stuff,
they're like totally cooked. They're like completely incapable
of engaging or providing evidence or said they're like literally
queuing on, right? They just come and they're like, "Yeah, Destiny
said this is the way it is. Storm's coming, guys." It's very
very funny. There was a clear bearing drain. Yeah, but here's
the thing. It doesn't matter. The the cultist will come back
eventually, right? with no like real reason or understanding
of why
like like nothing has changed in terms of the moral implications
of what he's done. Nothing's changed unless I guess you just
feel like Pixie pursuing this has changed your mind like Pixie
is such a that she deserved to have her like now. I guess you
could you could think that. I guess be interesting to see what
some of these people think. There's a lot of people who have
come back and I don't know if they like actually talk about it.
I would just be interested in their commentary on it to say like,
"Hey, like why why like back on this guy's stream?" Like I I'm
just curious why. Like what do you think happened? Could you
in for DJ of the year? Maybe your Discord can get you enough
votes two years in a row. Damn. >> You think they're still
doing that? You think he's still going to do that?
>> The DG awards. Yeah. >> Yeah.
Jeez. I think the only thing that Pixie can do now is film a
higher quality showcasing that her dick sucking has gotten better
with a circumcised
that is actually over 6 in. >> You listen, that's a that's
a bingo on the most offensive things you could say in a single
sentence. All right. Man should get a bingo like immediately.
>> I think that's the only thing she I think that's the
only thing she can do.
>> And he needs to be black. And he needs to be black.
>> Can't condone that. >> That's crazy. Disgusting.
>> You don't condone interracial
>> Yeah, just that part. Everything else that was said
I'm fine with, but just the interracial relationships.
>> gross. Rule 11 sanctions against Banell are warranted
for exhibiting a deliberate indifference to obvious
Furthermore, Rose's testimony also reveals that because A, she
was aware of Banell being catfished through the imposttor account
and that explicit material of her would be shared with Banell.
Banell was making requests for explosive material and that c
materials were being shared in this manner and then at times
shown to her, she was at least indirectly communicating with
based
argument. True.
This person, by the way, who told me that they were 18 or 19
years old. This person who I no no claims whatsoever about this
person being a minor ever. Number one. Number two, I'm not even
talking to this [__] person. I'm talking to a person
operating the account catfishing. Okay. But based we're basically
we're we're basically
we're basically besties is what my good friend Carlos here is
trying to say. Thank you, your honor. >> No, it's just
that you're exchanging like there's a go between in there.
Is that a big ass hot chocolate that he >> The foot >> I
have no >> stating that Bunn was exchanging material with
the minor is not incorrect. So So I guess so Pixie was too then
the fact no Pixie didn't receive anything from them and Pixie
had no idea like like the minoring in question. You thought you
were that minor. You didn't know she was a minor but you thought
you were the person who was of those pictures. She thought she
was you. She was you right?
He's saying like, "No, you couldn't possibly say I was exchanging
with this person cuz like I didn't know what was going on." But
it's like, "No, you were getting what you wanted. There was just
somebody in the middle that you were unaware of." You were sending
material to them. You were getting material from them, the person
you thought it was. And then you were just unaware of the person
in the
So Pixie was sending it too, right? Cuz it's transitive. No.
No. It's very different situations. >> Fact that Solo acted
as a go-between. A
The guy who was trafficking her is a go between. I'm just kidding.
That's >> Why is he doing He's trying to do the like Kai
Sonat
like
Yen yelling on stream thing and it's not working. It's not working.
>> Yeah, it's like this performative like, "Oh my god,
are you really saying that? Oh my god, >> chat. What the
hell? What the hell,
And it doesn't Yeah. It just doesn't work. It's like it's just
very obvious what's actually being said. Like when it's very
obvious what's actually being said, it kind of seems silly to
everybody. It's just a Hutch impression. It is kind of a Hutch
impression. Okay. It is,
dude.
And also and also it's particularly disgusting when you see it
from the guy who just like 15 minutes before this, 20 minutes
before this was arguing he was too emotionally distraught to
pursue the legal case against the child trafficker.
>> That's so funny.
>> he doesn't want to get he doesn't want to get uh uh
Connor in trouble because him and him him and Connor have have
been running a whole legion of of
across the internet and that's why they're in
>> I can believe that.
My one of my favorite donations here is like Connor counterpoints
would literally hold a child down while Destiny them and just
chastise him the whole time. Destiny, this is so bad. It's like
holding the kid down. Destiny, this is so bad. You should stop
doing this. This is like totally crazy right now. >> Yeah.
Yep.
>> Absolutely. Go between
[snorts]
doesn't alter this assertion. Well, I mean it kind of does, but
okay. The is he going to say how
is he going to say how it alters the assertion? America
with China for, you know, a certain some like dashboard or something
that they put in a car. Okay. And Destiny goes, um, actually
technically three other countries are involved in that trade
and um and and that means that they don't trade with China for
No, like those countries source to China or or those countries
are like an intermediary before it gets to America. It's like
it still happens that they trade with China for it. Yep. That's
still a thing. It's like there is an exchange happening there.
Just because you put an intermediary in the middle doesn't mean
that there isn't exchange happening
Anyway, fact remains that Beno requested explicit material of
a minor and that the minor provided it for him and he received
it and viewed it. I no indication that this person was underage
at the time. I'm not requesting anything directly from this person.
I'm not even sure. I should go through if they offered this all
or if I was requesting anything. I would have to go back and
check. I don't even know if I request anything. This person was
forthcoming with a whole bunch of but this person apparently
was her creepy weirdo adult boyfriend from the UK who was running
the account but okay he's like what I don't even know oh she
was forthcoming with a whole bunch of about what indication but
okay the fact remains that Beno requested explicit material of
a minor and that the minor provided it for him and he received
it and viewed
>> Okay, this is a just a straightup fact.
How is he going to deal with the facts? >> No indication
that this person was underage at the time. I'm not requesting
anything directly from this person. I'm not even sure. I should
>> He thought he was requesting things directly from the
person.
>> You see how he does the little words so that he can
say it's wrong, but he's not actually he's not challenging the
statement. He's saying uh I didn't there's no indication that
she was under 18 at the time. Yeah. Why did you ask for ID? Also,
I did not ask her directly. I did not ask her for any of that
directly. I did not I would never solicit child
from somebody being trafficked except through their pimp.
Okay. I don't what where are we saved here? Well, I don't know
what's what's happening. What's happening? Go through if they
offer this all or if I was requesting anything. I would have
to go back and check. I don't even know if I
I mean, wouldn't that be Hold on.
I I'm just spitballing here. Wouldn't that be a direct lie? And
wouldn't Destiny have access to the unredacted copies of this
if she didn't actually get requested for any if he if Destiny
made no requests for anything? Wouldn't that just be a lie that
you could point out? One of the first ones you can just point
out of like a obvious and specific lie on their side. You could
like totally do the dance of victory on it.
Why aren't you doing the dance of victory on it if that's the
case? Aren't there actual logs of him asking if she has any vids
of her giving head? Oh, maybe I I'm sure somewhere in those disgusting
sex there's something where he's requesting some material. I'm
almost positive, right? I request anything. This person was forthcoming
with a whole bunch of but this person apparently was her creepy
weirdo adult boyfriend from the UK who was running the account.
But okay. And while Rose repeatedly testified that she did not
message directly with Bonell, she also testified that she did
not recall whether she ever spoke to him via other means. I honestly
don't remember if I ever called Bonell. Moreover, Bonell produced
in this case his communications with individual with a screen
name straight which included messages on November 29th in which
he states that he had decent length phone calls with Rose multiple
times about both of our personal things. Never had a problem
issue fight over literally anything else. I thought I had at
the time it's possible that
um he said her boyfriend was running her cash app. Why would
he know anything about her cash app if he's not requesting anything?
Oh.
Uhoh.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. That is actually kind of true.
Why? What was he using the cash app for?
>> There was another person I was chatting with on the
phone instead. I know that this Rose person offered to call me
or we talked about calling. Um although at this point apparently
Solo literally could have just had her call me and we we would
have talked that way. But none of this is material to any of
this stuff. Um, I think after I said this when Pixie file >> I
love how he he keeps saying this rose person to like just really
drive it home how little he knew her.
This rose person
>> and he basically brings up, so I don't know if you remember,
but he told Pixie and I believe straight raid that he had multiple
calls with this person. They were very close to him and like
he had every reason to trust her, right? And he goes now, now
he goes like, >> "Hey, um,
>> hey, just so you know, uh, guys, it was two years before
that and I just found out that so many videos of me had leaked
online. I was stressed and I just totally forgot that I didn't
really know this person that well, right?
It's like, >> okay, you said it multiple times and you
were just saying it to like get out of trouble. You just you
just made up you just said something that got you out of trouble,
right?" At best, you have like a mal adaptation that you're going
to lie to people or you're going to say the thing that will get
you out of trouble as much as possible with whatever happens
in any given situation so you can figure out what to say, right?
Like it's an obvious thing. You just you said immediately to
a bunch of people. Actually, I had so many conversations with
this person when you were like pretending you felt bad. You didn't
want them to get upset and sue you. >> Very goofy. >> His
whole audience is like food shops now. Like they're all like
turbo a like nobody normal watches him anymore. Nobody normal
is like rooting for him anymore. It's like just a bunch of like
turbo that are going to like
kill their girlfriend in 5 years. >> Uh maybe
seems possible. Oh, hold on. I'm looking for something. What
am I looking for here? Oh, I was going to grab the dev thing
now. Hold on.
You know who Short >> Otans? Yeah. Do I know who what?
>> Um Short Fat Otaku. You know who that guy is? >> Short
Fat Taco. That was my nickname in high school.
>> Damn. No. Short battle. Otaku. SF.
>> I don't Chinese.
>> He went on uh the Wick TV panel tonight and then did
some random sweeping for Destiny. I would never have known about
this. I feel like anybody who found out about this. The fact
that this clip was linked to me, okay, while Wick was live, that's
very embarrassing, okay, that you watch Wick while he's live
with nobody's on his stream. Just saying. Just throwing it out
there. >> Just saying. Just saying. >> Maybe 10 cents
again. I don't know. >> Oh, you know what? Admiral Gibb's
not a nobody. Dev's not a nobody either. Dev's just a totally
disingenuous loser. >> Rakashi Rakashaya
asks you this, Dev,
why did you defended
their words, not mine? Destiny's revenge on a minor. You actually
dared to victim blame her and said it was all false
>> I feel like that's a SCOP donation, by the way. I feel
I'm pretty sure that's a scop donation.
>> Like that's like literally not at all what anybody claims.
>> I don't even know what this is. Okay. Is this in reference
to the Rose stuff? >> I'm not sure
>> because like this sounds like it's mixing up possibly
three stories into one story. You know what I mean?
>> Like I I was actually before the start I was going over
the latest court >> Does cutter have breasts now? Is he
on
I think those are supposed to be packs,
>> Oh, well, they're rude. >> They're looking like
breasts. >> Case rude. And I mean, it seems like Rose wasn't
even a real person at this >> So,
it's like, well, I don't know exactly what you're talking about,
dude.
>> Person at this point. Document drop on that case. And
I mean, it seems like Rose wasn't even a real person at this
like Rose wasn't even a real person at this point. How did Destiny
dox her then? How did Desi know so much actual information about
her? If she's like a madeup person, why did they use her actual
like real backstory, her real like life identity as a part of
this? Like where she went to school, all the stuff so Destiny
could leak it. If that was their goal from the very beginning,
okay, was to like sign up Destiny so that they could I don't
know totally with him. If that was their only goal,
why did they provide her real identity? Like all all the elements
of her real
I I wonder. Sorry, not her name. I mean like her her real school,
her real major, like where she lived. Why did they provide all
that stuff? It seems very goofy to me. >> It's like, well,
I don't know exactly what you're talking about, dude. I don't
know if you know what you're talking >> Okay, if you want
to clarify by giving me more money, uh, you more [laughter] than
Well, >> so Rose isn't a real person according to dev.
Rose, apparently, Rose isn't even a real person.
This guy is so disengaged. Just looking to collect a face. >> He's
at least not a real adult.
>> Well, she's a real adult now. But
this guy is supposedly he was like somebody who's like quite
smart. He's like in commentary spaces. People actually have to
start going after him for this. It's like he's actually like
pretty gross >> the way he uh handled this stuff. He's
like he's such an obvious liar about it, >> Someone should
do this guy. [laughter] >> No, no, no, no. I mean like
do content on him. Like just just press him for a response. like
actually press him for a response somewhere.
>> he's also a big member of the food shops community.
Like he's a big what do you call it? Um like he's a >> he
was big on defending food shops when people were calling her
originally. He very much likes food shops. There's not a single
trans person online that this guy won't try to get in on a firstname
basis with. You know what I mean?
>> guys. Like the the omni chaser. It's going to be like
Destiny, but he is the omnichaser instead of the omni liberal.
>> Wow. No, I didn't say anything like that. Lav is joking,
by the way. Do not do anything like that. It's stupid. Stop.
That's all Lav. That's not me. That's not me. >> I'm just
kidding.
[laughter] >> I don't even know who this guy is. I'm sure
he's fine. >> I can punish someone who willingly chills
in food shops chat. Pre-estiny bump, by the way.
Dude, he Yeah, he was a big food shops defender before as well.
It's a massive food shops defender. Just really likes food shops
for some reason. case. I'm pretty sure I went back and I checked
the logs that I had. By the way,
I just don't know. I don't know what he gets out of that in terms
of long-term because I think the thing that I I it was explained
to me that apparently he's made some good calls like defending
people on allegations in the past, but I don't know. I just wonder
if he like happened to pick a couple that he got lucky on or
what. Cuz when he when you ask him like why he's defending Destiny
or why he thinks some of the some of the things he says, he can't
defend any of them. Um, this happened on Twitter. I was like,
"Hey, do you want to come on stream and talk about this or just
explain like what you mean here?" And he was like, "No, I don't
think so." And then he told a bunch of people I was like trying
to him in the back, which I was very shocked by. And then later
he tweeted, actually, I was totally he tweeted on that same thread.
He quote tweeted himself and said, "I was actually vindicated
on everything that was said here." And I was like, "Hey, do you
want to talk now and like you could explain to me how you were
vindicated?" Silence
again. very crazy >> that Pixie has as well because unlike
her, I actually produced my discovery information. There are
no calls in our Discord history and I have no calls in my phone
logs about calling any phone numbers from or anything else. So,
um, do you think it was a woman or someone using a voice changer?
No. If I would have called her, it would have been around the
time when all the crazy Lauren was happening, but there was another
person I was talking to, too. So, my guess is I was just talking
to this person, but um, I was texting the this rose this solo
person, I guess, a lot as well. But I don't even know what the
story. Why would I lie? >> If he would lie about this unless
>> gotten together with Lauren,
>> all of this none of this would have
None of this would have happened.
>> Uh-huh. Yeah. Probably. Probably not.
>> Uh, might happen still. Didn't you hear that they were
apparently outside of Lauren de Laguna's workplace? Her and Lauren
Southern. Did you hear about >> Wait, what?
>> Her and Lauren Southern. Sorry. Destiny and Lauren Southern
were together in Austin, Texas, and they went to Sixth Street
and ran into Lauren De Lagoon at her job. >> Whoa. Southern
was there.
>> Yeah. Her and Desty were hanging out.
>> dude.
The clip. I don't even know where the clip is. Hold on. Hold
on. Wait. I'll try to find the clip. One second. Where is this?
Uh, I don't. Somebody linked a clip. I don't have like links
to anything on Dusty's Twitter. It's [__] up. It
is kind of crazy.
I don't know. I don't know what happened. Kind of unfortunate
for her, >> dude. That's so sad. >> Yeah. I don't
know if you followed any of her stuff. It was like >> I
read her article about being raped,
>> but it was that one was not bad. That one seemed like
relevant and fine. >> True. one about how
>> No, sorry. I meant like in terms of she's like a totally
disingenuous thrifter loser and this one seemed like honest for
once, which was cool >> and like a pleasant departure from
the norm. But then I read her article about how she was like
getting SCPed by the
by the Canadian government. And it's like what it actually ended
up being was just like obviously a Canadian intelligence agent
who wanted to her like she plays the recordings and he's like
trying to talk to her about how he wants to help her and stuff.
It's like oh it's very obvious this guy just wants to you. I
don't know how you didn't pick this up. It's very funny
>> but it was like about how they were trying to coersse
her into
something. So this is what this is like two weeks ago. >> Looks
like garbage in this
>> how you doing? Wait, did you not Oh, did you just not
know that Lauren Southern was here, but you knew about this?
>> I saw I didn't see the full video, but I saw um I saw
like the the AI of them in like uh as [snorts] black. >> Okay.
All right. All right. Yeah.
So, they were they were just um having a good old argument in
the middle of the >> That rocks.
>> Ryan's Ryan Beard is bigger than Southern right now.
What do you even mean by that, Machica? What? Huh? Huh? What?
What? Huh? Why did he not cover that on stream? Why did I not
cover that on stream? Why did Destiny not? Destiny did, and I
think I did, too. I'm reverbing through you just a little bit,
by the way, just so you know. Okay, hold on. Let's uh let's get
back to this. I'm going to try to get through this a little bit
more. What do I have after this? I've got like a bunch of stuff
I was going to watch tonight, but I don't know if we're getting
there. Um, we'll see. I'll be right back. I just have to use
bathroom and let the video play. Oh, well, I guess the logistical
discord theory is that I contacted Rose ahead of time and then
me and her um >> Oh, right. We watch this and these [__]
rule 11 sanctions. Like Jesus, >> I just I just everything
god damn >> if you guys are listening cuz apparently you
listen on my streams. I can email you the statute. >> We're
somewhere around >> like these are big claims. Like if
you want to have like a formal actual case
after Andy receipts and >> I don't know if there's anything
else here. Hold Let me check the timestamps. Yeah, I feel like
Wait, Lav, did you watch any of the Akos sing stuff? When I say
the Akos Singh stuff, do you know what I'm talking about? >> No,
I have no idea what you're saying. I hope also you cannot hear
me pee.
>> Uh, definitely could hear you a little bit. Kind of
weird. Don't talk. Um, >> that's awesome. >> Okay.
Uh,
>> I don't know if I can do a quick video on it. We'll
see.
>> Private Hoff, thank you for the gifted sub. Let's go.
How much time we got? We got 43 minutes. Yeah, we we do more
stuff after this. I'm just going to check the time stamps I was
sent for this and see if there's anything else here. And if there's
not,
>> I should probably move on. Oh, I see. So, apparently
this is after >> I don't know. I don't know if I want to
do this yet. Hold on. A little bit later. I can't do that yet.
Uh, just listen to this for a little bit. I'll be right back.
>> And see, the issue is at most an objection. He may raise
any motion in le what is it? Lemon
lemony
at the appropriate juncture. Indeed, as of the state, Binel served
his rule 11 motion. Binel himself has yet to set for deposition,
which further highlights the calculated miscellaneous nature
of his premature rule 11 motion. Bal's rule 11 motion to send
harass plate pressure and abandoning relevant claims. They're
not relevant. By voluntarily striking them from her opposition,
thereby demanding that she wave her right to raise these issues.
You don't even have standing for these issues. What the are you
talking right to raise these issues on be on whose behalf? What
are you talking about?
As noted, a careful review of his rule 11 arguments reveals about
does not in fact be the Rosa minor one. True. There were there
were probably hundreds of millions of miners on the planet. Do
you think that Bratler has polished up enough on his time cube
to compete with Joan P? Cuz when they reply to you pointing out
the 23rd is after the 10th by noting that midday is just the
shadow of midnight. I don't know if Andy will be prepared. True.
Wow. Very cool. All right. I don't know. Oh, yes. Hold on. Apparently,
he pulled up stuff from Discord to complain more about Wicked
Supreme and uh and Cyber or esports Batman. Apparently, he's
getting more logs from the Discord. We have more Discord viewing
on the stream today. Guys, are you aware that this is like one
of his favorite pastimes? Lab is just getting like dozens of
images from my Discord, just logs, and he just reads logs from
the Discord. >> Often totally irrelevant. Totally not like
literally not relevant to anything. Let's check it out. Let's
see. Let's see what's going on here. I think what he's going
to argue is this is why I need to dox these people is whatever
these messages are, he's going to say these are my pretext. These
are my why I need to dox these people now because they're evil.
Okay, so this is going to be some pretty heinous. This is going
to be some very heinous [__] coming out. >> Funnily
enough, Rose and Pixie did the same. But that's is all of Discord
server now because remember >> I would still admit to her
being not of age if he was trafficking her seems like a pretty
important question.
Um that's true. I think I think that's obviously true. Yeah,
it would be a little weird. >> So, that s guy installed's
discord server is openly bragging about in that server posting
emails. This guy created several email accounts, was harassing
Rose, was harassing her family, threatening them, telling them
like, uh, I hope that you contact Joan Peters. Oh, I see that
you haven't yet. I hope that you would have done the right thing
and I see that you failed to do that. It's very disappointing.
After they were getting doxed and harassed, by the way, by all
of Destiny is the person who doxed them originally. Just so we're
clear, Destiny docks them specifically.
Um, yeah. Destiny is the one who docks them originally. Destiny
is the person who put out the image that they were able to reverse
image search and docs Rose. He gave them her major, her college,
which gives where she lives, and uh the pictures of them, the
unique pictures that only he had of her that they used to actually
find her. So,
kind of kind of weird that he virtue signals over this. Very
weird. Even confirmed this was an adult. He said they were